in 2015 I watched a TED Talk by a long
now board member David Eagleman it was
about how to create new senses for
humans
uh turns out we can only see a tiny
little slice of the whole
electromagnetic spectrum the whole the
rainbow that we can see is is that
little bit bit right there
I'm going to take you into the
ultraviolet today
all right fluorescence that's when you
shine a flashlight of one color on an
object and and it glows a different
color think of like a you know shining
something on a 20 bill or like a
psychedelic poster okay in 1962 uh
natural fluorescence was found in a
glowing jellyfish in the in the 90s we
sequenced it we put it in another animal
and the people who did that got the
Nobel Prize for it
this is my childhood best friend Sam uh
he got his PhD in fluorescence and one
day he told me that he thought there's
like a lot of other stuff out there in
the ocean but we kind of brought the
jellyfish into the lab and forgot to go
back outside and keep looking so I
started thinking
so inspired by David Eagleman and Sam I
got scuba certified and I bought a black
light
it sat in a drawer for like six months
waiting for my next dive but then I was
like I wonder if things on land glow
so I started exploring I took my first
night hike within 15 minutes or so I saw
this glowing moth and I was hooked
since then I've been like spent many
moons out there in the dark exploring
the world in ultraviolet light and I'm
finding all these crazy things like glow
so
problem is my photos were really blurry
back then enter my friend Henry he's an
amazing photographer travel blogger he
he encouraged me to get better to get a
better camera get better lighting and
taught me how to use it so the photos
started getting a little better around
now
the pandemic hit in 2020
I couldn't go scuba diving but I
realized oh I could find some ocean
creatures in tide pools so I started
exploring the California tide pools
this is one of my favorite discoveries
so these are Pacific mole crabs this is
right down the street from the Long
Island offices
um basically like when the when the
water comes in they stick up these like
feathery antenna they grab food and then
the water Retreats and they pull them
back in again it's really beautiful
all right I wanted to explore another
biome my friends Hansen who's a
biomimica expert she opened the brego
institute for living design in the
California desert
so I did a creative residency down there
when I found this
all right remember Sam
well we're back in Maine for the
holidays he had heard about this otter
living at this pond in a cemetery so we
went and go to go see it with his family
I still don't know if otters glow but I
got an idea while I was out there
graveyard more like graveyard
like and glow like crazy like crazy
everyone gets like a unique portrait of
you know Pain by Nature after they die
and it's painted over millions or
not Millions but hundreds of years it's
a girl with a snail earring she was like
10 feet high it was hard to hard to
capture there's like sprinklers hitting
me every 30 seconds the snails are
moving really fast
all right so what is lichen lichen is
actually a partnership between algae and
a fungus so it's not a single organism
it's a partnership so here the red is
the algae and the yellow is the Lichen
starting to starting to lichenize it
basically
the algae makes makes food from sunlight
and the Lichen basically creates a
greenhouse for it turns out this
combination
is what has created soil the liken are
the Pioneers basically they come they
come to like harsh Landscapes they break
down the soil and they can even survive
in space
all right back down to earth here's a
here's some backstage
so I was in the cemetery I called up
Henry for advice he's on a beach in
Thailand with models
you can see me like really regretting my
life decisions here
so next stop Thailand
just kidding I went to the UK to find
some more graveyards
I wanted to find some older stuff
because like and grow is very very
slowly as I told you
all right
I bet now you're wondering like you're
starting to get curious I hope you're
maybe starting to let go of some
certainty starting to invite in some
curiosity maybe you're wondering what
around you glows why things glow
how they glow or maybe you're imagining
your own tombstone
David Eagleman thinks that there's like
a bunch of Nobel prizes hidden out there
I agree I think there's a whole new
branch of science I think there's a
whole new genre of photography
and I think we have to find it
I think we have to find it collectively
because it's like too much for me so I
think we should start assist in science
project to go explore the outdoors at
night so come join us at gloweth.org
thanks very much
thanks
[Applause]